today on the Matt wall show daycare
employees are pushed to promote
non-binary identities on their children
in their care meanwhile a public school
employee in Tennessee says she's
quitting the profession because she
can't groom her kids anymore without
interference we'll talk about all of
this today Plus Memphis Police prepared
to release body cam footage of an
alleged police brutality incident but
everything they've done leading up to
the release makes it seem like they want
the riots that they claim they're trying
to avoid and a clothing company
romanticizes self-mutilation in an
attempt to promote their products and
our daily cancellation a leftist
YouTuber tries to take me to task for my
quote authoritarian views on criminal
justice we'll talk about all that and
more today on the Matt Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
welcome to another flannel Friday
everyone now you know that I tried to
remain humble I certainly don't like to
brag but when I receive a major award in
recognition of my work I think the most
humble thing is to acknowledge and show
gratitude for it and so I must say that
I am grateful to start this year off
with not one but two prestigious Awards
the first came at the beginning of the
month
um we talked about when the new Republic
named me the transphobe of the year for
2022 as I said at the time I'm Blown
Away by the honor the competition was
obviously formidable there were several
worthy nominees who have been doing
important work in the field of
transphobia But ultimately I took the
prize and I couldn't have been more
thrilled a fantastic way to begin the
month and the year and this is a this is
an almost as fantastic way to end the
month the Anti-Defamation League which
of course is a far left activist group
they put out a report this week naming
the biggest amplifiers of anti-lgbtq
plus extremism and here's how they begin
their report
they say in recent months a handful of
high followers social media accounts
have driven the rapid spread of
dangerous and false narratives designed
to marginalize and demonize the lgbtq
plus Community online amplifiers of
anti-lgbtq plus hate and extremism use
their influence to push baseless tropes
and conspiracy theories to their
millions of followers
these claims are frequently picked up by
Major far-right media personalities
expanding their Reach online amplifiers
are key players in an ecosystem of
anti-lgbtq plus hate that drives online
harassment campaigns against lgbtq plus
individuals and groups and spreads
narratives which Inspire real-world
extremist activities threats and even
violence the center on extremism is
tracking several of the biggest online
amplifiers of anti-lgbtq plus extremism
now the list of those being tracked
quote by the extremism Center include
Libs of tick tock along with Chris Ruffo
The Blaze gays against grimmers and then
of course yours truly the transphobe of
the Year ADL describes me this way says
Matt Walsh is an anti-lgbtq plus
extremist commentator for the far right
media Outlet the daily wire as seen as
in his anti-transgender content such as
his documentary what is a woman Walsh is
one of the biggest purveyors of
erroneous and harmful narratives
surrounding gender affirming care for
transgender and non-binary youth his
rally to end child mutilation targeted
one such provider in Tennessee and was
attended by known violent extremists as
well as prominent right-wing politicians
Walsh has over a 1.2 million Twitter
followers and nearly 2 million YouTube
subscribers and his content is regularly
promoted by mainstream conservative
media figures such as Piers Morgan Joe
Rogan and Tucker Carlson
now actually I have over 2 billion over
2 million YouTube subscribers not not
nearly 2 million but who's counting
besides me every day the point is that I
have again been honored and recognized
for my transphobic extremist efforts
and I feel greatly blessed by that
now
as humbled as I am to win these trophies
I sometimes suspect maybe I'm paranoid
but I suspect that maybe they don't mean
for it to be taken as an award
because it almost seems like they think
will somehow be upset to be labeled this
way and even intimidated to know that
we're being tracked it's as though they
imagine that I'll be like in a group
chat with Libs of tick tock and Chris
rufo frantically message them it's like
yo guys the center for extremism is on
to us it's time to lay low
but unfortunately for them that is
not exactly how we react to these sorts
of things
actually the ADL and Media Matters and
all the rest of them they do find
themselves in a little bit of a bind
it's kind of a lose-lose situation
because on the one hand we are
encourageable bastards so you can't shut
us up or change our minds with insults
or intimidation in fact we find it
amusing we like it so you only encourage
us encourage us more when you do that
we're happy when we upset you
if you work for Media Matters or ADL or
Southern Poverty Law Center
there is nothing negative you could say
about us that won't make us happy
because we're so happy to have upset you
people that's what we want to do
but on the other hand if you ignore us
completely
well then we're free to engage in our
extremist activities without resistance
so there really are no great answers
that's why you have to feel kind of
sorry for them I mean I don't but maybe
you do in fact I I have for my part
never been more encouraged and
determined to continue down this path of
extremism especially given two other
stories from this week now the first one
is a video posted to social media by
Jordan Chamberlain who works with the
Washington Free Beacon and it's a clip
from a documentary called reflecting on
anti-bias education in action the early
years
and it was reportedly presented by the
North Carolina Association for education
of young children to a group of daycare
providers in the state
here's the clip watch this
huckleberries
today
I wanted to introduce you to a new
friend in our class
well this huckleberries is my friend
Nash
it's their first day in our class
they're just looking around at all of
you and they're so curious to know who
you all are
today uh
was fun it was really interesting though
knowing going in being like
I don't know what questions kiddos are
going to have or what they're going to
say
um which is both like nerve it racking
but also kind of exciting it's that
place of
um not knowing as a teacher and just
being okay with that
and the friend likes to ask the question
are you a boy or a girl
and mash answers I'm just a kid
but a kid but kids can be boys they can
be boys or girls yeah or maybe
non-biased yeah
it was just like
non-binary yeah that's just something
that we know and this is something I
mean it's like
they're four and five years old and they
just didn't make a big deal out of being
a boy or a girl and I think it was a
huge Testament to how much we've been
talking about it in the classroom that
you never mentioned the term non-binary
it was yeah yeah a child who brought
that up because it's constantly in
conversations
ah yes a testament to what they've been
doing in the classroom uh that it is
she's right I mean what's fascinating
about that clip is that we get the
propaganda and and then the reality
right next to each other first we hear
from the teacher who tries the familiar
maneuver of pretending that a child's
acceptance of Concepts like non-binary
and transgender is proof somehow of the
concepts self-evident validity to the
kids it's normal they say the kids
accept it without a problem so why do
you adults have an issue with it
yes well why is it normal to the kids
why do they accept it why do they repeat
the jargon the other teacher lays it out
plainly they accept it and repeat it
because they constantly hear about it in
the class from the teachers
the teachers are hammering these ideas
into their heads which results in the
kids what do you know having these ideas
in their heads
isn't it so amazing how if we
continually tell them something over and
over and over and over again eventually
they repeat it
isn't it amazing how kids work that way
no it's not amazing that's how every kid
works
in fact you don't even need to repeat
something over and over and over again
for them for the kid to pick it up and
repeat it too
like any parent that's ever been in a
car and uh you know got cut off in
traffic and you let a profanity slip out
and then you hear it repeated in the
back from the kid who you thought wasn't
paying attention like you know how
kids are like sponges and they hear a
word one time and they repeat it now if
you take a word like a concept term like
non-binary
and you say it in the classroom not just
once but over and over and over again of
of course they're going to repeat it
and this is why they're so desperate to
introduce gender Theory to children as
young as possible because they they
don't even want to wait for kindergarten
they want to get to the kids when
they're still in daycare the younger the
better because the younger a child is
the more willingly he will accept
incoherent ideas without skepticism and
as the history of the human race clearly
attests if you get someone to believe
something early in life they'll most
likely continue believing it all the way
to the Grave children are not skeptical
of anything adults are only skeptical of
new ideas right I mean that's most most
adults very few adults show any capacity
to apply skepticism to ideas that
they've always held children aren't
skeptical of anything adults are only
skeptical of the things that they are
newly introduced to
and even then many adults aren't even
skeptical of that
that's the game here
and it's why they've turned daycares and
elementary schools into LGBT
indoctrination zone is also why
we have to oppose these despicable
groomers with every fiber of our being
the opposition does matter and it does
make an impact
and if you need to be convinced on that
ladder Point well consider this
unintentionally encouraging testimonial
from a groomer teacher here in Tennessee
listen to what she says
I have no idea what comment this video
goes back to but the comment like
there's a groomer flag in the background
I was able to pull a screen grab and if
you see in my old classroom I had my
pride flag right there it's in a
different spot in my new classroom it's
still there here's the thing I am going
to quit
I'm 100 going to quit and it is because
not comments like this but it is because
people like this have taken over or
starting to take over education and
education is not what it once was and
it's not worth it anymore I support
every single one of my students no
matter what their views are this
it just get
I have to say uh to the extent that I
can take partial credit for helping to
create the environment that is so
hostile and demoralizing to this teacher
driving her out of the profession in
frustration this is an even greater
honor than winning transphobe of the
Year this teacher has declared that it's
not even worth teaching if she isn't
able to sexually indoctrinate children
actually it's not worth teaching if she
encounters any pushback in her efforts
to sexually indoctrinate children
she demands the ability and had grown
accustomed to running her indoctrination
Camp without opposition or or any
accountability whatsoever
she Pines for those days and laments
that they are gone
and now she is leaving in protest
which is fantastic one down many more to
go
this is exactly why we have to keep the
pressure on
yes we want to push for policy changes
as we have done yes we want to persuade
people we want to make the argument all
of that but we also want to frustrate
and demoralize the enemy
until they decide that it's simply not
worth the heartache to continue
that is part of the strategy here
frustrate and demoralize them
we want them to know that as long as
they insist on treating children this
way they will encounter opposition and
it will be relentless
and it will come from people who cannot
be emotionally blackmailed
cannot be cowed into Silence by
accusations of bigotry
people who are so stubborn and
frustrating to you that in fact when you
try to put labels on us we'll make a
joke out of it and celebrate it
that's the only way that's how we put a
stop to this and the plan is working
slowly but surely
now let's get to our headlines
if you're on a business the past few
years have been a bumpy ride from covet
lockdowns to bite inflation you could
probably use a break and Innovation
refunds can help with that if your
business has five or more employees and
manage to survive covid you could be
eligible to receive a payroll tax rebate
of up to twenty six thousand dollars per
employee it's not a loan there's no
payback it is a refund of your taxes
period uh the challenge is though
getting your hands on it how do you cut
through the red tape and get your
business the refund money that it's owed
well go to getrefunds.com that's how you
do it getrefunds.com their team of tax
attorneys are highly trained in this
little known payroll tax refund program
and they have already returned one
billion dollars to businesses and they
can help you too they do all the work
with no charge up front and simply share
a percentage of the cash
uh that they get for you businesses of
all types can qualify including those
who took PPP nonprofits and even those
who had increases in sales everyone is
potentially uh eligible for this so go
to getrefunds.com click on qualify me
and answer a few questions as payroll
tax refund is only available for a
limited amount of time don't miss out go
to getrefunds.com getrefunds.com
all right we'll start with
this daily wire has this report five
former Memphis Police Department
officers are in custody and face several
charges after their involvement in the
death of a 29 year old male who died
earlier this month in a hospital days
after a confrontation with authorities
Tyree Nichols died on January 10 three
days after Memphis Police pulled him
over at a traffic stop stopped Nichols
and the five former police officers
involved are black so everyone involved
is black which uh
shouldn't be relevant but it is because
we know that that these kinds of cases
are
usually assumed to be uh racism white
supremacy
whether or not there was actually any
police brutality involved well there's
no argument for that here there is no
place to make this racial there's no
place to talk about white supremacy but
that isn't going to stop the media and
the activists from doing it
um authorities stopped Nichols on
January 7th for reckless driving near
raynes Road and Ross Road in Memphis
Police told local media that during the
stop a confrontation occurred at which
point Nichols ran away from police on
foot as they attempted to apprehend him
while attempting to take the suspect
into custody another confrontation
occurred however the suspect was
ultimately apprehended after the suspect
complained of having shortness of breath
at which point an ambulance was called
to the scene
um and then the suspect died a couple
days later
local media
reported authorities were charged with
official misconduct through unauthorized
exercise official power official
misconduct through failure to perform a
duty imposed by law official oppression
second-degree murder aggravated assault
and aggravated kidnapping causing bodily
injury and aggravated kidnapping while
possessing a weapon
so these are all the uh
the charges now
it's the attorney Bill Massey
represented uh representing
Martin told local media that he was
indicted he's one of the officers and
turned himself into authorities Memphis
police chief Sarah Lynn Davis issued a
statement Wednesday night about the
investigation unless she's this is what
she wrote in light of the horrific
circumstances surrounding the death of
Tyree Nichols it is actually incumbent
upon me your Chief to address the status
of what of what the Memphis Police
Department is doing has done and will
continue to do in furtherance of finding
truth in this tragic loss ensuring we
communicate with honesty and
transparency and that there is absolute
accountability for those responsible for
tyree's death
this is not just a professional failing
this is a failing of basic Humanity
toward another individual
adding that the five officers involved
in his death failed our community and
they failed the Nichols family
uh and then she goes on from there I
mean this the Memphis Police Chief and
other officials in Memphis and other
political and law enforcement officials
have been talking about this video for a
couple of days now leading up to its
release sometime today before Friday
night and as I'm speaking right now you
know the video has not been released I
haven't seen it
but they've been talking about it for
days
and the Memphis police chief in
particular has been
has used the most dramatic possible
language to describe it
you just heard some of she's all she she
has said that what's on the video uh
what's captured in the video are acts
that defy Humanity okay so she's using
the kind of language that you would use
to describe like a war crime or a
genocide
and once again I haven't seen the video
so uh it it may be as bad as she says
I don't know I haven't seen it so it's
like I I believe in this in this uh very
radical approach of I don't make a
judgment call about a video Until I've
seen it myself
and I haven't
but this is the language that she's
using leading up to it being released
and it's more than that too we have uh
this interview she did with Don Lemon
this was last night
and I just want you to listen listen to
a little bit of uh
of what she says listen to this
let's talk about the video yes
um
it has been said that it is reminiscent
perhaps worse than the Rodney King video
is that your assessment that's my
assessment I was I was in law
enforcement during the Rodney King
um uh incident and it's it's you know
very much aligned with that same type of
behavior and it's worse sort of group
think
um I would I would say it's about the
same if not worse if not worse if not
works so take us through the video
tonight
um when it is released
it has been said there's over an hour
there's
um the pole cam they said the sky cam
and there's body One camera video what
are we going and how is it going to be
distributed are you going to put it on
social media are you sending it to the
media how is this going to be
distributed actually we plan to post it
on a YouTube link so that it can be
accessible to just about anybody who
wants to access that video and we'll be
pushing that out later on this evening
the video is broken into four different
sort of uh
fragmented pieces but they're all right
so you get the you got the idea so she
she uh she says that this is this video
is worse than Rodney King
um it's worse than the Rodney King video
and once again I haven't seen it so
maybe it is
um but I haven't seen it here's my point
if you don't want riots
then
you would do exactly the opposite
of what the Memphis authorities are
currently doing
um if you don't want riots and you're a
competent
person and you're a competent leader you
do these the exactly the opposite
because what they're doing right now is
that they are they are emphasizing ahead
of time that this is horrible it's the
worst video anyone's ever seen it's a
crime against humanity it's potentially
the worst police brutality beating of
all time that's ever been captured on
film
and they're saying that for days ahead
of time leading up to releasing the
video on a Friday night
so if you wanted riots then that would
be the best possible way to do it I I
couldn't imagine a a more effective way
of handling this
um if you want riots you hype it up
ahead of time you tell people you give
people the most dramatic possible
framing for this video before they've
even seen it
rather than letting the video speak for
itself if the video is as bad as that we
don't need you to spend two days telling
everyone but hey guys this is so bad I'm
telling you it's the worst thing if it's
that bad let people see they can see
that for themselves you know we don't
need we don't need the police chief to
frame it for us like that
and then to make matters worse all of
that framing leading up to a Friday
night release so you've got the build up
you're giving people time to plan you're
giving the out-of-town agitators time to
to to to mobilize
um and then right when everything is
kind of frothing uh and everyone is Mo
is is congregating that's when you
release the video
like that you throw in the hand grenade
right into the middle of it
right lighting the match after
everything is soaked in gasoline
I don't know how else to interpret this
I mean this is like
the video is not even out yet and this
is the worst handling of a of a you know
of a situation like this that I've ever
seen
it really is
the only possible argument in favor of
what they're doing is if you say that
well this is Mo you know they're
releasing it on a Friday because this is
a the Friday news dump uh strategy where
you put it on a Friday there's not a lot
a lot of time for the media to Hype it
up uh people are doing other things and
and uh and you know that's that's often
what you do when you don't want people
to when you don't want a big deal to be
made out of something then especially in
politics you release it on a Friday well
that doesn't work if you're hyping it up
ahead of time and telling people that
it's the worst thing ever
then the Friday news dump now you know
what it's not a Friday news dump it is a
Friday premiere
even here in the video it's like it's
almost like she's
an actress promoting a film
she's like well you know in that video
that we'll be pushing out uh later this
evening
just release the freaking video we don't
need we don't need you on camera for
days ahead of time
weeping over it we don't need that
you're the police chief you're supposed
to be a leader in this situation
which means you use Clear language
that is not emotionally charged
and you say well what if it's a really
horrible thing then then
especially in that case you don't want
to be emotionally charged other people
can be emotional you're supposed to be
the leader
which is what you keep your emotions in
check
and you try to keep the temperature down
describing something as a videos by
saying it's it that they is acts that
defy Humanity
and it's one of the worst things I've
ever seen
that is not keeping the temperature down
this is really a
you know it's possible there still won't
be riots you know because it is cold so
that might be enough to keep the rioters
away
um generally it's not a coincidence that
rioting usually happens
when it's a little bit nicer out it
usually happens in the spring and the
summer that's rioting season typically
so it would be uh
a little bit unusual in that way if we
did have writing but then again
they've done everything they can to hype
this thing up and to build it up
and this is Memphis we're talking about
like it doesn't take much
to get uh Lawless hordes out on the
street in Memphis I mean they're already
out there so it doesn't take much and
we'll we'll see what happens but
uh now I I do you know I I try to always
keep in mind the maxim
which I think is a very important one
that uh uh
you know never attribute to malice that
which can be more easily explained by
stupidity
and sometimes there's stupidity and
Malice involved which might be the case
but maybe that's here you know maybe
they don't want riots but they're just
really stupid and incompetent and so
they they actually think this is the
best way to handle it
as far as describing motive
you can make your own judgment call
all right
what do we have next year uh this is
from the daily daily mail rather
a new advertisement from Burberry
featuring gender-neutral models has
sparked outrage for glamorizing girls
having healthy breasts removed uh the
British fashion House's latest campaign
features a topless young person with
scars from a double mastectomy a
procedure that can be used to remove
cancer or for those transitioning
genders
burberry's latest campaign that is
entitled be mine celebrates intimacy and
embrace
intimacy and embracement
is that a word I don't think that is
celebrates intimacy and embracement
and critics have assumed that the model
is transgender
well
seems pretty obvious
um I don't think advertisements should
be normalizing in fact glamorizing girls
having healthy removed one critic said
throughout the campaign real life
couples are captured expressing their
moments of embrace while each couple is
also dressed in a selection of Burberry
gifts Burberry shared the new campaign
on his Instagram account where it has
received hundreds of comments
um do we put the picture up
so we have the picture of this of what
this campaign looks like and it is
it is uh
a clothing designer there it is
so there you go
it's a clothing designer promoting
glamorizing
romanticizing self-mutilation
this is really no different than a
stylized clothing ad that had that would
you know show a girl showing off her
scars that are on her arm from where she
cut herself or imagined an ad with a
rail thin bulimic woman puking in a
toilet like it's the same kind of thing
it's the glamorization of self-harm
that of course is not the media's
headline here listen to uh this is the
Newsweek headline
new Burberry ads Sparks Republican
meltdown
and so for them the the headline of
course
is not
the fact that a clothing company is
promoting girls removing their healthy
breasts
you know cosmetic double mastectomies
that's not the hell that is to Newsweek
that's not the headline
the headline is that people are upset
about it
now of course we know this is the
media's game the old Republicans pounce
maneuver
but it's the same it's the same deal
here
this is
you know
anti-life anti-human
it's hard to think of something more
anti-human than celebrating promoting
glamorizing and romanticizing uh
self-harm that
that human beings inflict on themselves
all right
this is a story from the daily wire
which is a 15 year old girl from New
York was issued a sentence of three to
nine years on Tuesday after submitting a
guilty plea over lethally stabbing a
pier the girl's name was not disclosed
because she's only 15 years old the
Westchester County District Attorney's
Office released information regarding
the sentencing stating that the girl had
pleaded guilty to first-degree
manslaughter for the deadly stabbing of
Kayla green who was 16 years old at the
time of her death a teenage defendant
senselessly took the life of Kayla green
and doing so left a community devastated
as a family and the Mount Vernon
Community remained in mourning I want to
reiterate my commitment
to working with our Vital Community
Partners for Meaningful violence
prevention and intervention especially
for our youth this is from district
attorney Miriam Roca
um
so she wants to do everything she can to
prevent violence
and
everything you can to protect
you know people from from being victims
of violence
and the solution then is a sentence of
three to nine years
for stabbing someone to death
and I get that she's kids 15 years old
that's a kid
and so it's a it's a tragic thing on
multiple levels
they have a 15 year old
whose life has gone so wrong that
they're already lashing out murderously
then you have another girl who's dead
that's the greatest tragedy of all
you know and it's a tragedy on both
counts
but what is solved here so you give
three to nine years that means it's
really going to be three years or less
than that
um and this girl is out when she's 18 19
years old so you take a 15 year old girl
who's already a murderer
he's already the kind of person that
would stab someone to death
and then you throw her into you know a
jail for three or four years
but are kind of
hang out in that stew along with other
criminals
and then release her back into society
when she's 18 or 19.
what have you solved that way
this is exactly what we talked about
earlier this week and we'll talk about
again a little bit in the daily
cancellation
you know this this is why it makes
people upset it makes them uncomfortable
and squeamish when you talk about what
actual Law and Order would look like
and what it would entail
but you should be upset and squeamish
about this
the dangerous murderous people
who we take them and our solution is
just to put them in a building
with other dangerous murderous people
for a few years and then release them
back into society
where statistically it's almost certain
they're going to victimize more people
and everybody involved knows that
the system knows that
right everyone knows the court system
knows that this person when this person
is released from jail
everyone involved you know in the system
will know we're going to see her again
she's probably gonna kill somebody else
and we're gonna see her again and
everyone knows it
and then we we sit back like impotent
helpless there's nothing we can do about
it
well there's something you could do
about it which is to keep this person in
prison
and again I understand 15 years old the
idea of taking a 15 year old putting her
in prison for potentially for life
or certainly for decades you know
that idea is uh it's a very sad thing
someone throw their life away like that
but but the other option the other
solution is totally untenable
um another way to look at it is you know
when you have the criminals to do
terrible things
um in order to keep Society safe
a a sacrifice must be made
there's gonna be sacrifice made you know
um
either
they we take the criminal and they're
going to be forced to sacrifice their
freedom potential potentially
permanently or depending on the crime
they may have to sacrifice their own
lives you know if it's a capital crime
uh so and that might make you upset to
think about but that's that's one option
the other option is that's is that
innocent people in society and the
community have to sacrifice potentially
their own lives so we don't we don't
want to make the criminal sacrifice
their freedom or their own lives and so
we release them back into society and
now a sacrifice is made of innocent
law-abiding
citizens
who end up falling victim to that
criminal we just released back onto the
street
now you might prefer that there would be
a solution where no one has to sacrifice
anything nobody has to sacrificed their
life no one has sacrificed their freedom
nobody is hurt nothing bad happens I
agree that would be the best solution I
would prefer that
you know but that doesn't exist
all right daily wire again uh former
Baywatch star Pamela Anderson has been
busy promoting her newest Project A
Memoir love Pamela and a Netflix
documentary titled Pamela a love story
and she has reportedly netted some
backlash for claims she made in both and
Anderson's Netflix documentary for
example the actors claimed that ah the
actor Sylvester Stallone once
propositioned her allegedly offering a
fancy car in a condo in exchange for her
green to be his number one girl she says
she turned down the offer but Stallone
says he never made an offer in the first
place
um
Anderson also claimed in her upcoming
Memoir that the actor comedian Tim Allen
once exposed himself to her on the set
of Home Improvement the actress Cass is
a tool girl in Tool Time and she claimed
that he opened his robe and flashed her
in what she said was an effort to even
even the score after seeing her naked in
Playboy magazine
yeah just
a general principle here
like I have no idea if any of that is
true
General principle uh and I've said this
before that if you if something bad
happens to you someone does something to
you that's bad and you wait for years
and years and years or even decades and
you don't tell anybody until you have a
book to sell
or until you have a Netflix documentary
that you're trying to promote like if
the first time you're bringing something
up is in an effort to promote something
you're selling
then we are going to automatically
dismiss your claim
even if it's true I mean we can't know
so long ago as part of the problem
waiting so long we can't know if it's
true or not and so it's no way for us to
know he said she said type of thing
uh which means that we can only go by
context and the context here is that you
are using this to sell something and so
it's it's
you had all that time before it to bring
it up you waited until you had something
to sell which means that we just can't
take it serious
because you don't take it seriously you
obviously don't take it seriously if you
didn't say anything until you finally
until you figure well this would be a
great way to get some publicity for this
book
nobody would know right like nobody
would know or care that Pamela Anderson
has a memoir coming out I wouldn't know
about it you wouldn't know about it
except for that Tim Allen store it's the
only reason you know that obviously is
not a coincidence all right one other uh
thing or maybe one or two other things
but this
this is a guy that we've seen in the
show before
um Jeffrey Marsh
and he's all over Tick Tock he's on the
other social media platforms and uh he's
a professional
groomer this is what he does Grooms and
indoctrinates
and um that's that's all he does and he
doesn't even try
what's interesting about this guy is he
doesn't try
to hide the Predator Vibes at all he's
not doing anything to hide that and so
here's his latest video watch
if you need a family
you can come hang out with me
they may not see the real you
but that does not mean that you're not
real
I love you very much
I'm gonna go cry
with love
like I said not trying to hide the
Predator Vibes it couldn't be any more
explicit than if he recorded that video
uh in a you know in a in a in a white
cargo in a nondescript white cargo van
if he pulled up in the cargo van
and unrolled the window
and said hey kids if you need a family
I'm here let's hang out
couldn't make it any more explicit
but this is also this is not just
grooming though it is that
this is also this is this is
cult
indoctrination to a t this is cult 101
stuff what you're saying here
uh it's Predator 101 and cult 101 and
obviously those two things are very much
linked
so well if you're if your family rejects
you if your family doesn't want you
around I'll be your family member
forget about your family you don't need
them
you just need me I'm here for you
that's cult indoctrination and and what
makes it even more terrifying is that uh
it's it's kids are not only encountering
that message on Tick Tock and social
media it's bad enough there but this is
also of course uh what they're getting
in the schools
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
[Applause]
Nick says I'm an artist have been for
over a decade I'm not nearly as educated
as any Master but I feel better than uh
these modern artists and I could say
Matt is 100 right about how arms and
mainly hands and feet are the most
difficult thing for even the most
skilled artists sometimes including
myself it's the reason why a lot of old
art portraits have men putting their
hand in front of their coat and and to
the other uh and the other to to the
side and hidden or finding another
creative way to conceal the hands
yeah that's that's what I suspected for
a lot of these uh especially the the
sculptures and monuments and that sort
of thing it's like I can't even I mean
taking a chunk of material a stone or
something
and chiseling it away to create
an image you know I I can't even
conceive of what is required the kind of
skill that's required to do that and
then to get all the finite details down
especially hands and all the rest of it
um takes an enormous amount of skill so
when I see these Modern Art sculptures
the first thing I think and maybe I'm
also being informed from my own
experience of being a you know in school
and cutting corners and finding ways
around things
uh I I the first thing I think is like
okay that's that's your way around
having to do the difficult task of
creating real art
uh
Joe says death threats to Eric swalwell
the Assassins would most assuredly be
silent but deadly well done Joe I I
once again I feel uh you know that I
wish I could tell you that that's a dad
joke that I decided to skip over because
I was being more mature but I I didn't
even think of it I didn't draw that
connection and uh so I'm a little bit
ashamed of that
but thank you for for your work Joe
uh Evan says Matt I've worked for a
large tech company in the past trust me
the meetings that the Google employee
took were the least productive part of
her day I think that's the case and like
almost any company
that's that it's and I don't do a lot of
meetings historically I've I've never
done a whole lot a bunch of meetings but
I don't know of all the meetings I've
ever been in in my life
maybe five percent of them are actually
productive
and then the other 95 it's like mostly a
meeting it's not just in tech companies
I think this is anywhere mostly meetings
happen because uh
for one thing it's just people feel like
they need to have something on their
schedule and it's really it's just it's
a it's a process of people justifying
their jobs that's that's all it really
is the meeting is there so that everyone
can take a turn justifying their
existence in the company that's why the
meeting exists
and that's why that's what makes
meetings
even more frustrating for it like if
you're if you're in a company and you
know what your job is and you're doing
your job and you're productive and all
of that when you're forced to sit in a
meeting it's it's all the more
frustrating because you don't need to
justify your job and all you're doing is
sitting here listening to other people
do that it's all it's a big performance
uh Tony Catman says Matt in respect of
the modern art things are in fact worse
than you thought there are people who
are still doing classic sculpture jogo
for example talented and dedicated
Unfortunately they don't get the public
commissions or attention they deserve
the best are still commissioned by
private collectors but this is probably
the best way uh things this is probably
the way things always happened
yeah I think and I don't I don't doubt
that at all which is why yeah this is
this is the case with all forms of art
whether we're talking about the
paintings or sculpture or music or film
or anything like that
um when people complains oh nobody's
making good music anymore no one's
making good movies anymore no one's
making good sculptures anymore
and I and I have been known to complain
like that
but what we really mean is that the
culture doesn't celebrate or elevate
good art it exists I mean they're always
going to be artists out there and good
artists but the question is what is your
culture what what does your culture
Elevate and celebrate
and that's uh the problem and also fund
is a big part of it
Ivy says hi Matt I'd really like to hear
your thoughts on Disney adults we got a
little piece of it in Daily cancellation
but Disney obsessed adults who go to
park several times each year with or
without kids and decorate their homes
and vehicles with Disney items seem to
be growing demographic in our generation
I'm curious what you think about them
are you curious what I think about them
are you actually curious you don't is is
there any doubt in your mind
about what I think of Disney adults
who are obsessed with Disney and go to
Disney even without kids
and wait in lines to meet the costumed
characters and have little costume
character figurines in their home do I
do I need to lay out how I feel about
those people
I can't stand them as if I needed to
that's what it is
now I'd like to address something that
you've sure all been wondering I'm sure
is you know you may ask Sweet Daddy how
do you always look so sharp and handsome
and well rested with six kids including
two newborns and a Theocratic fascist
dictatorship to run what's your secret
now this is obviously privilege
information but because the depths of my
generosity knows no bounds I will tell
you this every night I curl up on my
giant walrus and read my book Johnny The
Walrus the world's most comforting work
of LGBT children's literature and it
works every time for me luckily we offer
the Johnny The Walrus book and plushie
in a convenient bundle over at
dailywire.com shop so you too can look
as radiant and vivacious as I allegedly
do go to dailywire.com shop to get your
Johnny Waller's book bundle today you
don't want to miss out on it also
the daily wire is looking for a new
Director of Human Resources the problem
is that most of them are from woke
companies who waste all their time
focusing on pseudo diversity equity and
inclusion initiatives we don't do that
here we need an experienced HR
professional who isn't afraid to roll up
their sleeves put in long hours and
competently run an HR department if this
is you and you stand up against the
mainstream leftist agenda we want to
hear from you so for more information
and to apply head to dillywire.com
careers that's dailywire.com careers
today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
foreign
earlier this week we discussed our
pathetic impotent criminal justice
system which has utterly failed to
maintain Law and Order in our
communities it's a justice system that
seems to be uninterested in Justice and
I proposed as you recall that we take
off the kid gloves and start dealing
harshly with criminals Predators those
who've turned our cities into wreaking
zombified wastelands in fact I advocated
that we adopt some of Singapore some of
Singapore strategies in this regard
strategies that have helped to make
Singapore one of the safest and cleanest
places in the world while our cities
look like massive drug-infested garbage
dumps specifically I believe that we
like Singapore should adopt corporal
punishment for thieves and robbers and
vandals and the like and uh you know we
used to use corporal punishment on kids
in school now we've decided that it's
too mean to even use on multiply
convicted felons and I find that
attitude absurd and weak
the criminals also find our justice
system absurd and weak which is why they
have no respect for it and they have no
fear of breaking its laws and I also
believe that we like Singapore and like
Donald Trump has frequently suggested
for this country we ought to expand our
capital punishment regime to include
drug traffickers those who distribute
and sell Mass amounts of poison slowly
killing thousands of people every year
ought to face the ultimate penalty
nearly every murderer who has ever been
executed in the United States inflicted
less damage and killed fewer people than
the most prolific drug traffickers
there's no reason why drug traffickers
should get a more lenient sentence
indeed there's there's no reason why the
death penalty should be reserved only
for those who directly kill people
sometimes the most heinous kinds of
predators have other ways of preying
upon their fellow human beings child
rapists would be another example
with our ridiculous laws as they stand
in Most states you can't execute a child
rapist unless they're also guilty of
murder
as if the crime of child rape itself
doesn't warn it
I mean they deserve to die for their
crimes whether they directly kill their
victims or not
this is the case I made and I explained
my logic I think in extensive detail
still it has proven to be not
surprisingly controversial people on
both sides of the political divide are
deeply scandalized by my argument
Twitter has been basically unusable for
me over the past few days well it's
always basically unusable but especially
over the past few days because my entire
feed is just people screaming at me for
wanting to punish criminals
now look it's okay if you disagree with
me I I will I will give you permission
until my Theocratic fascist regime
officially begins anyway for now you do
have permission to disagree with me uh
you're wrong but but that's okay you can
be wrong
my problem is not that people simply
disagree with my proposal but that they
treat the mere notion of harsher
penalties for criminals has somehow
absurd on its face they recoil at the
suggestion that those who traffic
substances that kill thousands every
year should be given the same punishment
that we already give to other kinds of
murderers
they scream out in horror at the very
idea that perhaps we should sentence
robbers and thieves to corporal
punishment rather than letting them hang
out in prison for a few months and then
releasing them right back into the
community with no additional penalties
you know this is the issue
that you're not a stupid person for
listening to my argument finding it
unpersuasive and making a counter
argument I'm you know that doesn't that
that's that's fine
but you are frankly pretty damn stupid
if my argument is so shocking to you
that you can barely articulate a
response or if you think it's so
unthinkably extreme that it isn't
necessary to articulate a response
that kind of reaction to a perfectly
reasonable suggestion one with a massive
amount of historical precedent shows a
lack of thought on your part and an
ability an inability to even entertain
any challenge to Modern orthodoxies
because that's really the problem right
is that what I'm saying flies in the
face of our kind of generally accepted
Notions of how to deal with criminals
and for that reason alone many people
are upset by it then they can't explain
really why it's just it just doesn't
comport with what they've always been
told and sort of the general atmosphere
that they live in
speaking of people who can barely
articulate a response that brings us to
YouTuber Kyle Kolinski who's the owner
of the secular talk Channel on YouTube
and um like most YouTubers on the left
every so often Kyle likes to use my name
to drive engagement and every so often I
will respond because well I I can't help
but take the bait So Yesterday Kyle put
out a video titled Matt Walsh's fascist
mask slips on Twitter
and he's part of the mob terribly upset
about my comments though he liked the
rest of them can't quite explain why
now most of Kyle's video consists of him
calling me stupid and authoritarian
while making incredulous facial
expressions
um not really a counter argument not
much to respond to but I did want to
address one part of it and it's this
part listen
Singapore is able to have nice things in
part because they execute drug dealers
by hanging
and arrest even Petty vandals and
thieves and beat them with a cane until
they bleed
we don't have nice things because we
aren't willing to do what is required to
maintain them
then he goes on to say
there are some accusing me of advocating
similar laws in this country and I just
want to clarify that yes absolutely I
want those laws in this country
okay
Matt Walsh is an authoritarian
and it's hilarious because the daily
wire Matt Walsh and others like to go
after the left and say oh the lifter
authoritarians and they hate Freedom bro
they hate Liberty bro
you hate Freedom you hate Liberty part
of freedom is being able to put in your
body whatever you want to put in your
body as long as you're not hurting
anybody else being able to sell said
substances in the same way I don't think
we should be hauling away the CEO of
Budweiser in handcuffs I don't think you
should haul away the weed dealer
he's saying
execute drug dealers
all right dog
you want to start go find the CEO of
Pfizer
and moderna
go find the guys who make Xanax
okay sounds good to me I mean yeah we'd
have to give the big Pharma Executives a
fair trial of course convict them in a
court of law but once that's been done I
absolutely would want them to face the
same penalty that should be imposed on
any other drug trafficker see Kyle
you're not going to trip me up by
demanding that I take my arguments their
logical conclusions because I will
always do that I'm not afraid of doing
that that's the advantage to being
logically consistent okay so you go you
said when you say well if that that's
how you feel then then that would lead
to this sure sounds good to me let's do
that too
it's an advantage of being logically
consistent that you yourself do not
enjoy because you have already made a
number of statements that I'm quite sure
you would not want to apply with total
consistency so you say that part of
freedom is not only being able to put
whatever you want into your body but
also being able to sell anything that
someone else might want to put in their
body
now here's the problem this argument
already assumes that freedom is itself
the highest good and therefore literally
anything that falls under the banner of
freedom is automatically good and and
should be permissible
but that's a case you need to make okay
you can't merely assume that
you haven't made it here or as far as I
know anywhere else
see I don't believe that freedom is the
highest good
I don't think that the ideal Society is
one where people are simply able to do
whatever they want all the time
I don't really think that I don't really
think that you think that either
actually I'm quite sure that there are
things that you would say people should
not be free to do
I'm quite sure of that
and yet your whole argument rests on
simply labeling drug trafficking part of
freedom
so already we have a number of logical
inconsistencies and sort of half-baked
ideas
well let's talk about drug traffickers
for a moment now you um
keep making this this uh this you want
to make this about weed first of all and
I've noticed that with all the people
that are arguing with me talk about drug
traffickers all they want to do is talk
about weed they bring it right to eat I
didn't specifically say that I said drug
traffickers
okay and you do that because you know
you'd sound ridiculous defending
fentanyl dealers on the basis of freedom
okay so you go for the for the easiest
form of the argument you can find
and you want to make this about
marijuana
but I'm not gonna let you off the hook
that easily so let's let's focus on
fentanyl dealers for a moment
they traffic and profit off of poison
just straight up poison that destroys
the lives of thousands of people and
kills thousands more and you say this is
okay because the people who use it want
to you know they want to use it so that
makes it okay
well why does their desire
to use the drug automatically make it
okay to sell it
is that the standard anything that
somebody might want to use is
automatically okay to sell
is that really is that really how you
think the law should work
and again your argument rests on an
assumption that you haven't actually
defended or explained
which is that freedom is the highest
good it's a good in and of itself and
anything that can be labeled Freedom
automatically should be allowed to
happen
besides even if the fentanyl user has
consented the entire rest of the
community plagued by the filth and crime
and violence the drug causes have not
consented okay the dealer might consent
the user might consent we'll get to that
in a second but the people forced to
live in communities utterly ravaged by
this poison do not consent to it
the people who are hopped up on these
drugs and then they run on to you know
run to a subway platform and throw an
old lady in front of the train she
didn't consent to that
she didn't consent to be a part of this
she didn't consent to living in a city
that's The Walking Dead with drug
zombies walking around
oh and also by the way the user doesn't
consent either they're addicts they're
not making Clear Choices they are acting
out of desperation and compulsion and
addiction
the dealers and traffickers exploit that
for financial gain there's no Freedom
here Freedom has nothing to do with drug
addiction who the hell could look at a
heroin addict or a fentanyl addict or a
crackhead and say well that's Freedom
that is the opposite of freedom
so to review freedom is not a
self-explanatory defense of drug
trafficking it's also not a relevant
defense because one of the things that
makes drug trafficking so evil is that
the end user does not actually have
total freedom because they are enslaved
by the drug
but let's take addiction out of it let's
take drugs out of it okay let's let's
make this
even easier for you
you just said that people should be free
to sell
whatever anyone else wants to put in
their bodies
that's what you said
now I think that this is an utterly
ridiculous argument when it comes to
hard drugs but it's also ridiculous when
it comes to things that are not Drugs
That's How thoroughly ridiculous your
argument is so here's a thought
experiment just a thought experiment
Tide Pods you may remember a few years
ago when there was much consternation
over the tide pod challenge where an
idiots on Tick Tock or YouTube or
whatever would eat the laundry detergent
capsules and then get very sick and in a
few cases would die now here's the
question what if the Tide detergent
company
decided that it wanted to lean into this
phenomenon so it began selling its
product as both a laundry detergent and
a snack
what if they put on their packaging Tide
Pods great for laundry great for
snacking and what if they even well
let's just say that they're being a
little bit more responsible they include
an FDA warning that though it can
physically be eaten it might be damaging
to your health
but still even with that warning they're
marketing it they are marketing it as a
consumable product remember you said
that people should be free to put
whatever they want to their bodies and
sellers should be free to sell whatever
anyone wants to put into their bodies
some people wanted to put Tide Pods in
their bodies why couldn't the tide
company therefore sell Tide Pods
specifically to that demographic put it
in a snack aisle next to the to the
potato chips
explicitly for the purpose of consuming
why couldn't they in other words
intentionally poison their customers
directly
what would be wrong with them sitting
around in a marketing room and saying
you know what some of our customers want
to be poisoned and killed by this let's
think of some ways to sell it to them
let's think of some ways to Market it
not just Market it to people who already
want to consume Tide Pods but let's try
to convince people that they should eat
this stuff
and then sell it to them
the argument you made in defense of
fentanyl dealers would cover this tide
company hypothetical absolutely
now maybe you escaped this bind by
plunging forward and saying yeah sure a
tide should be able to legally Market
their product to those who want to eat
it
now that would make you consistent at
least but it would make you consistently
insane because you would be defending
the freedom of Corporations to
intentionally and directly poison their
customers
which would only go to show that freedom
in and of itself is not a valid defense
and of course you never did explain in
that Clipper and any other part of your
diatribe what is so wrong with
non-lethal physical punishments of
criminals
actually when even simply putting
someone in prison is a physical
punishment involving physical coercion
and force
should we abolish prisons too while
we're at it
and if we shouldn't abolish prisons
meaning that physical force can validly
be used to punish criminals then why
should we automatically rule out
corporal punishment which is but one
form of physical Force
well we'll take it one step at a time I
suppose Kyle still needs to figure out
whether laundry detergent companies can
sell their products as a snack
um I don't want to overwhelm him with
things so we will let him think about
that but for the time being we will also
say that he is canceled and that'll do
it for this portion of the show as we
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not talk to you on
Monday Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]